[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to "Coffee with a Googler."
Today, I'm meeting
with Ankur Kotwal
to talk all about Google
Maps and great things
that you can build them.
We'll even have a chat
about the Santa Tracker app
that Ankur worked on.
Ankur, I've been a Maps
developer for a while.
I love doing it.
And almost every time
I go to anything Maps,
I see your videos,
I see your blogs,
I see stuff that you've done.
So it's great to have you here.
But tell us all
about Google Maps,
and what it is that
you do with it.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
I'm part of the Google Maps
API developer relations team.
And what we do is,
we are a conduit
between third-party developers
and our internal engineering
teams.
So as third-party developers
give us feedback on our APIs,
or they talk to
us about use cases
that they'd like
to see us address,
we take that feedback to our
product and engineering teams.
They then take it, and
prioritize it, and start
to build those things out.
And then we have a
team of tech writers
that write the technical
documentation that you
see at developers.google.com.
We have a team of
engineers that actually
build libraries and samples.
And in fact, they
like to see themselves
as the 0th customer of the API.
[CHUCKLING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Typical
engineer-- is the 0th customer.
ANKUR KOTWAL: That's it.
And so they get to have that
initial first feedback pass.
And then we have developer
advocates like myself,
like yourself, that go in,
then tell the developers
that we've built this that
we've taken their feedback on.
And then the cycle repeats.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
So it's great that
this stuff isn't just
built in isolation, right?
You've got folks like
yourself, who are there
as that conduit
between the developers
and the outside world-- and
the engineers who are actually
building it.
But I hear you've got, like, a
little bit of an announcement
of some new things
that you're going
to be doing in that space?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
So actually, to take that
relationship with the community
further, we've just recently
launched the Google Maps API
beta program at
developers.google.com/maps/beta.
And what this really
is is a way for us
to get feedback on APIs
before we launch them.
And for developers,
the advantage
is, they can see
the types of things
that we're working
on ahead of time
and catch us at that point
of our development cycle,
that they can give us
feedback that's quite
meaningful and actionable.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So we
can take that feedback,
make any changes to
the product, make sure
that at the time we launch
it, the quality is there,
but also its usefulness
is really there.
So it's available-- it's
out now for sign-up.
You know, we are looking to
take people in in batches.
So if anyone sort
of hits the site
and sees that the
form is closed,
we will open it up
again at a later time.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, cool.
So what was the site again?
ANKUR KOTWAL:
Developers.google.com/maps/beta.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Am I
allowed to go sign up?
ANKUR KOTWAL: I think you
have special access already,
Laurence.
[LAUGHING]
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now, one of the things
like with Maps that
I remember seeing--
and I know it's a project
that you've been working on,
and I've been dying to ask
you about it-- is the Santa
Tracker.
You've been doing this as
a 20% project at Google.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
It's a 20% project that's
a true labor of love,
because we work
throughout holidays,
and over the
end-of-year holidays,
and Christmas Eve
and Christmas Day.
But basically, the reason
we love to work on it
is that it brings joy to
children and adults who
feel like children.
And so, the point is that
throughout December, we
can play some games on our
website-- on the Android apps,
as well, we have some games.
And then on Christmas
Eve, on December 24th,
when Santa takes off, you
can track Santa's progress
through the world as
he delivers presents
and he stops by your
city, and so on.
So we started working
on the Android app
about four years ago.
I was one of the
founding members of it.
And I love contributing
to it every year
and just watching all
the reactions online
as people use it
throughout the holidays.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now, does this
get you off his naughty list
and onto his nice list?
ANKUR KOTWAL: I hope so.
[LAUGHING]
But no, it's just-- it's so
much fun working with him.
Because when we put the
Android device on his sleigh
so that he can give us
his location, you know,
everything has to work.
So we don't get
another shot at this,
and we don't even get
to delay our launches.
So it is actually
a lot more pressure
than you would typically expect.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's really neat.
And actually, I did
have one question
that inquiring
minds want to know,
as you are the Santa
Tracker expert.
It's summer now--
(WHISPERING) where is he?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Where is Santa?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Well, he's
relaxing, for starters.
Usually, we find that
he's relaxing on a beach.
He's often hard to reach
at this time of the year.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
He's earned a break.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
He definitely earns his break.
But if you happen to go to
the Santa Tracker website,
or if you have a look
at our launch videos,
often, he's coming off some sort
of island, or like a cruise.
It's funny-- for someone
that lives in the North Pole,
he enjoys warm weather.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Ah, I
can't say I blame him.
[LAUGHING]
Now, I hear you had a
really tough project
manager on this at one point.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I did.
It was my four-year-old--
or three-year-old son,
at the time.
So I had a newborn and
a three-year-old son.
And unfortunately, I told
my three-year-old son,
before my second son was
born, that I would build
a day-night cycle
in Santa Tracker,
so that when you touch
the sun, it would set,
and the moon would come up.
And when you touch the moon,
it would do the opposite.
At the same time, my
second son was born,
and so we were in and
out of the hospital.
But my three-year-old
son was relentless.
He would say to
me everyday, Dad,
does the sun go down,
and the moon come up yet?
And so I spent
many an hour trying
to build this out for him.
And it's the reactions
from people like my kids
that really drive me
towards Santa Tracker.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's
what makes it all worthwhile.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: But he
was a tough project manager.
ANKUR KOTWAL: He is tough.
He is really tough.
But he was happy
with the end result.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's what matters.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So I got
his tick of approval
at the end of the day.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Very cool.
Now, it's not just Maps, right?
Like in the Geo APIs, there's
a whole bunch of other stuff
that we can work with.
Can you tell us
about some of them?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
So typically, people
think of the Maps APIs
as the visualization pieces.
But it's actually
much more than that.
We have the sort of data APIs
through our web services.
So things like
the Directions API
are immensely
valuable, where you
can get the step-by-step
directions from point A
to point B. Actually, more than
that-- you can add waypoints
as well, to say, I want
to get from here to here,
but I want to pass through
this, this, and this.
And you can get it with
different modes of transport.
And then you can look at
ways to visualize that.
But these data APIs are
really, really valuable.
They help you create
some magical experiences.
The Places API is
another example,
where you can find out
about real-world places--
things like their opening hours,
things like their ratings, even
photos.
But my favorite will
probably be the Roads API.
So something that we
don't often realize
about our mobile devices is
that the GPS sensors on them--
they're not always
very accurate.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Uh-oh.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So
even though you're
driving along the
road or a path,
you'll find that the data that's
coming from your GPS sensor
is a little bit noisy.
It's a bit of a zigzag
rather than a straight line.
Now, developers came
to us and said, hey,
can you help us solve this?
Because we know that
the user is driving--
we know that they're on a road,
but we don't have a nice way
to represent this.
And so we built this Roads API.
So you can submit a
bunch of latlongs to it--
latitudes and longitudes.
And it will snap them to a road
and return them back to you
and follow the path of the road.
So it may even
insert more points
as you go through roundabouts
and things like that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice, nice.
I've noticed that on the
East Coast of the US,
the freeways tend to
have service roads.
So you can be on the
inside lane of the freeway,
and there's a service
road parallel to that.
And then sometimes
my GPS has me saying,
you're on the service
road-- get on the freeway--
and that kind of thing.
It gets confused
between the two.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Well,
at least it's a road.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's true.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Sometimes
you get GPS points
in, like, a field, right?
[LAUGHING]
And the Roads API
really helps there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool, cool.
You mention that you're
really excited by some
of the innovative
ways that developers
are using Google Maps and
the various Google Maps APIs?
Do you have an example
that you can share?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
Actually, you know, right
now, one of the big topics
of conversation is VR.
And what I'm really
interested in
is VR as an educational tool.
And so, when you start to take
Street View and put it into VR
and take that into
classrooms, and be
able to take young students
through the pyramids in Egypt,
through the Great Barrier
Reef, and show them
what it looks like, it's a
very different experience
to when you and I grew up, where
we'd look at pictures in books.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Draw a
triangle and-- passage here,
and--
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
And we had to use our
imagination a lot more.
But they get to see
what it's actually like.
And I think that's
really, really wonderful.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I've seen
the Barrier Reef VR experience
that you mention.
And the one thing for me is
that it put it into context
just how precious it is.
So when we talk about, like,
protecting the Barrier Reef,
it's when you see it
and you can feel it--
you feel more
emotionally attached
to wanting to protect it.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
And, I mean, I hope
it stays as pristine
as it has been in the past.
But now we have a snapshot
of what it looked like.
And you can really
experience it.
If you haven't taken
a Google Cardboard
and played with the Street
View app, you really should.
And the API enables
all of that, too.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Great example.
Thank you.
Now also, I know there's a
whole bunch of, like, helper
libraries to be able
to do some great map
scenarios, like polyline
encoding, and all
that kind of stuff for
Android developers.
Could you tell us a
little bit about them?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
So we have this open source
library called the Android Maps
Utils, and it has a
number of features.
I'm going to call out two
of my favorite ones, which
are different ways
to represent markers.
So often, you know, we
have markers on a map.
But sometimes, we're showing
lots and lots of data,
and different developers
deal with it differently.
Sometimes they restrict
how many markers they show,
and they'll restrict
to a view port.
But some visualizations
that you can
look at are things
like marker clustering,
so that as you zoom out,
it will combine the markers
and represent it in some visual
way-- typically, a number.
And then as you zoom in, it
splits up and then populates
the markers elsewhere.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So if you
zoom far out from a city,
and you're looking, for
example, at restaurants,
there could be 1,000 markers.
When instead of having
1,000 things drawn,
you're going to cluster
them into [INAUDIBLE].
ANKUR KOTWAL: Exactly.
Because there's no value in
presenting 1,000 markers--
LAURENCE MORONEY: There's a
big performance hit too, right?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
But how is the user
supposed to choose?
It's not meaningful
at that point.
So marker clustering
really helps.
And the other one is Heat Maps.
So again, if you're talking
about things like restaurants,
you can start to see
hot spots in a city
as to where some of the
more popular or well-rated
restaurants are.
And maybe you want to
just sort of head there
and decide on the spot
as to which restaurant
you want to eat at.
So Heat Maps are a really good
way to visualize that as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow, Ankur.
I mean, there's
just so much things
we've covered, from how
you're getting feedback
from developers to
the product teams
so that we can build stuff.
And the new beta
channel-- new beta program
that you're opening up.
Santa Tracker and
all this stuff that
was involved in that-- that's
like, that was hilarious,
and some good stuff there.
And now, just all of
the different things,
the different APIs,
the services APIs,
the Android libraries--
you're a busy man.
ANKUR KOTWAL: You know what?
It's the product that
really drives me.
The Maps API was one
of the first APIs
that Google launched,
and it's actually
been more than 10 years
since we launched that API.
And we've seen such
innovative uses of Maps
on the web and even
in mobile apps.
So I can't wait to see
where we go next with it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sounds good.
So thanks, everybody.
If you've any questions
for me, or if you've
any questions for Ankur,
just please leave them
in the comments below.
And don't forget to subscribe to
the Google Developers channel.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]